if aliens
were observing earth through the entire
history
just watching us and uh we're tasked
with uh summarizing what happened until
now what do you think they would say
what do you think they would write up in
that summary like it has to be pretty
short
less than a page like in uh hitchhiker's
guide
there's i think like a paragraph or a
couple sentences
how would you summarize how sorry how
would the alien summarize do you think
uh
all of human civilization my
first thoughts take more than a page
they'd probably distill it
because if they watched well i mean
first
i have no idea if their senses are even
attuned to similar stuff to what our
senses are attuned to or what the nature
of their consciousness is like relative
to ours and
so let's assume that they're kind of
like us just technologically more
advanced to get here from wherever they
are
that's the first kind of constraint on
the thought experiment
and then if they've watched throughout
all of history
they saw the burning of alexandria they
saw that two thousand years ago
in greece we were producing things like
clocks the anti-catherine mechanism and
then that technology
got lost they saw that there wasn't just
a
steady dialectic of progress so every
once in a while there's a giant fire
that destroys a lot of things there's a
giant like uh
commotion that destroys a lot of things
yeah and it's usually
self-induced uh they would have seen
seen that and so as they're looking at
us now as we move
past the nuclear weapons age into the
full globalization
anthropocene exponential tech age
still making our decisions relatively
similarly to how we did
in the stone age as far as rivalry game
theory type stuff i
i think they would think that this is
probably most likely one of the planets
that is not going to make it to being
intergalactic because we blow ourselves
up in the technological adolescence
and if we are going to we're going to
need some
major progress rapidly in the
social technologies that can guide and
bind and direct the physical
technologies
so that we are safe vessels for the
amount of power we're getting
actually hitchhiker's guide has uh
estimation about how
how much of a risk this particular thing
uh poses to the rest of the galaxy and i
think
i forget what it was i think it was
medium or low
so so their estimation was would be that
this this species of ant-like creatures
is not going to survive long
there's ups and downs in terms of
technological innovation
the fundamental nature of their behavior
from a game theory perspective hasn't
really changed
they have not learned in any fundamental
way how to uh
control and properly incentivize
or properly do the mechanism design
of games to ensure long-term survival
and then they move on to not the planet
you